it was 61 years ago that patrice lumumba
was executed by a firing squad in
democratic republic of congo with help
from belgian mercenaries
the belgian police officer cut his body
into pieces and dissolved it in a barrel
of acid but kept his gold tooth as a
trophy and took it back to belgium
at a ceremony in brussels on monday the
government returned the tooth to
delegates from congo and members of
lumumba's family
i would like here in the presence of his
family to reiterate the belgian
government's apologies for the way it
weighed at the time on the decision to
put an end to the days of the first
prime minister of the congo
belgium and its royal family earned vast
wealth from colonizing congo and
violently exploiting its people and its
natural resources
millions of people were killed
patrice lumumba became wildly popular as
he campaigned for independence from
belgium colonial rule
but belgium and the us didn't like his
democratic and socialist ideas and
supported those who killed him shortly
after independence
the mumbai's relatives have been
requesting the return of the tooth for
years
it's the only known remaining piece of
his body which they want to later rest
i can't say it's joyous but it is
positive for us it's positive that we
can finally bury one of ours
two weeks ago belgian king philippe
visited congo and expressed regret for
belgium's colonial past
he stopped short of apologizing
belgium's been trying to improve its
public image regarding its brutal
colonial past since the black lives
matter movement began two years ago
the movement prompted activists to
deface statues of king leopold ii in
belgium who colonised congo in the 1880s
some have since been removed belgium is
willing to take very symbolic gestures
very simple and easy acts but the acts
of repairing the acts of
allowing justice to to happen this is
not happening
the returning of lumumba's tooth is
certainly symbolic
congo still suffers from the kind of
brutal violence and exploitation of
natural resources that belgian
colonialists began there more than a
century ago
a ceremony in brussels won't change that
malcolm webb al jazeera